WE’LL FIND OUT.
>> Sandra: FOR MORE ON LAST
NIGHT’S BIG DEBATE LET’S BRING
IN LARA TRUMP.
GOOD MORNING.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU HERE THIS
MORNING.
HOGAN GIDLEY FROM YOUR CAMPAIGN
HAS ALREADY SAID PRESIDENT
TRUMP 100% WON THE DEBATE LAST
NIGHT.
DID THE PERFORMANCE BY THE
PRESIDENT CHANGE ANY MINDS OR
SWAY ANY VOTERS LAST NIGHT?
>> WELL, I AGLEE WITH KIM AND
THE CAMPAIGN ASSESSMENT.
I THOUGHT THE PRESIDENT DID AN
INCREDIBLE JOB.
LOOK, I THINK THE CRITICISM OF
HIM FROM THE FIRST DEBATE
SANDRA WAS THAT HE WAS VERY
STRONG AGAINST JOE BIDEN.
WE SAW LAST NIGHT THAT IF YOU
WERE LOOKING FOR THE PRESIDENT
TO COME BACK A LITTLE BIT, BE A
LITTLE MORE MEASURED WE GOT
THAT VERSION OF DONALD TRUMP
LAST NIGHT.
HE CAN DO THAT.
HE HAS ALWAYS SAID HE CAN DO
THAT.
BUT I THOUGHT HE WAS
PARTICULARLY STRONG WHEN HE WAS
ACTUALLY TALKING ABOUT THINGS
THAT MATTERED TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
WHEN HE WAS TALKING ABOUT THE
ECONOMY, REOPENING OUR COUNTRY,
GETTING KIDS BACK TO SCHOOL.
THE ENERGY INDUSTRY.
THESE ARE REALLY IMPORTANT
THINGS TO AMERICANS.
WHETHER YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT
THE TONE OF THE ENTIRE DEBATE
OR THE SUBSTANCE, I THINK THE
PRESIDENT PROBABLY DID SWAY
VOTERS HIS WAY LAST NIGHT.
WE WERE VERY PROUD OF HIS
PERFORMANCE.
>> Sandra: ARI FLEISCHER WAS ON
FOX NEWS A LITTLE BIT AGO AND
HAD SOME ADVICE FOR THE
PRESIDENT IN THE DAYS THAT
FOLLOW THIS DEBATE HOW TO BRING
IT HOME NOW.
WATCH.
>> THIS IS A RACE BETWEEN AN
OUTSIDER WITH RESULTS AGAINST A
TYPICAL POLITICIAN WITH NO
RESULTS WHO IS MOVING LEFT.
IF THE PRESIDENT DRIVES THAT
SIMPLE THEME HOME THE NEXT 11
DAYS, A LOT OF GOOD CAN HAPPEN
FOR DONALD TRUMP.
>> Sandra: HE SAYS THE
PRESIDENT HAS ONE JOB LEFT AND
IT IS SIMPLE.
DRIVE HOME THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN AN OUTSIDER WITH
RESULTS AND A TYPICAL
POLITICIAN WITH NO RESULTS WHO
KEEPS MOVING LEFT.
WHAT WILL WE SEE FROM THE
PRESIDENT AS FAR AS STRATEGY
WITH 11 DAYS LEFT?
>> WELL, YOU HEARD THE
PRESIDENT SAY THAT LAST NIGHT.
HE SAID I’M NOT A POLITICIAN.
THAT’S WHY I WON IN 2016.
AND HE SAID I RAN FOR PRESIDENT
BECAUSE OF THE FAILED POLICIES
OF CAREER POLITICIANS LIKE YOU,
JOE BIDEN.
HE LITERALLY SAID THAT TO JOE
BIDEN LAST NIGHT.
SO I DO THINK YOU’LL HEAR THE
PRESIDENT ECHO THAT MESSAGE.
HE HAS BEEN SAYING IT AND
CONTINUES TO SAY I’VE DONE MORE
IN 47 MONTHS THAN JOE BIDEN HAS
DONE IN 47 YEARS.
BUT LOOK, IT IS ALSO ABOUT
REMINDING PEOPLE WHAT THE
ACCOMPLISHMENTS OF THIS
PRESIDENT ARE.
SO THAT’S WHY WE’RE SPREAD OUT
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
OUR ENTIRE FAMILY INCLUDING THE
PRESIDENT AND VICE PRESIDENT
REMINDING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WHAT THIS PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
ABLE TO DELIVER IN RECORD TIME
AND WHY HE IS THE ONLY PERSON
THAT CAN BRING THIS ECONOMY
BACK AND GET US TO THE GREAT
HEIGHTS WE SAW NOT TOO MANY
MONTHS AGO.
>> Sandra: ONE OF THE BIGGEST
MOMENTS OF THE NIGHT LAST NIGHT
IS WHEN THE TWO HAD THIS
EXCHANGE OVER THE CORONAVIRUS
AND HANDLING THE PANDEMIC,
WATCH.
>> ANYONE WHO IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR MANY DEATHS SHOULD NOT
REMAIN AS PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
WE’RE IN A SITUATION WHERE
THERE ARE THOUSAND DEATHS A DAY
NOW.
>> President Trump: IT WILL GO
AWAY.
AS I SAY WE’RE ROUNDING THE
TURN.
WE’RE ROUNDING THE CORNER.
IT IS GOING AWAY.
>> Sandra: JOHNS HOPKINS
UNIVERSITY REPORTS THE SEVEN
DAY ROLLING AVERAGE OF NEW CASE
NECESSARY THIS COUNTRY IS UP
18,000 IN JUST THE LAST WEEK,
LARA.
DAILY NEW DEATHS IS UP 9%.
YOU HEARD THE PRESIDENT MAKE
THE CASE WE’RE ROUNDING THE
CORNER AS HE OFTEN HAS.
WHILE JOE BIDEN PAINTED A
PICTURE OF WHAT HE SAID COULD
BE A VERY DARK WINTER FOR THIS
COUNTRY.
SO DID IT HELP FOR THE
PRESIDENT TO TAKE THAT APPROACH
CONSIDERING JOE BIDEN STILL IS
POLLING ABOVE THE PRESIDENT ON
AMERICAN VOTERS AND WHO THEY
THINK IS BEST TO HANDLE THIS
PANDEMIC?
>> LOOK, AT THE ONSET OF THIS
THE PREDICTIONS WERE 2 MILLION
DEATHS.
OUR HEARTS GO OUT TO EVERYONE
DEALING WITH THIS.
THIS WAS HISTORIC WHAT THIS
PRESIDENT DID NOT ONLY WITH
TESTING, VENTILATORS,
PARTNERING WITH THE PRIVATE
SECTOR.
PAYCHECK PROTECTION PROGRAM.
ON THE PRECIPICE OF VACCINE IN
RECORD TIME.
SO WHEN THAT HAPPENS I THINK
WE’LL SEE A HUGE CHANGE ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
THE PRESIDENT HAS SAID THAT’S
PROBABLY WEEKS AWAY.
I THINK IT IS A TERRIBLE
MESSAGE TO SEND TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE THAT YOU HEARD FROM JOE
BIDEN THAT IT WOULD BE A DARK
WINTER?
WHY WOULD WE WANT TO BE SO
NEGATIVE AND DISMAL.
VERY DISTURBING TO HEAR.
YOU WANT A PRESIDENT WHO IS
POSITIVE AND UPLIFTING AND
KNOWS WHAT IS ON THE HORIZON AS
PRESIDENT TRUMP DOES WITH THE
VACCINE AND I THINK WE’LL SEE A
BIG CHANGE WHEN IT COMES OUT.
>> Sandra: WE SAW YOU AND THE
PRESIDENT’S CHILDREN WALK INTO
THE DEBATE HALL WEARING MASKS
AND WORE THEM THE WHOLE TIME.
WAS THAT A CHANGE IN HEART OVER
WEARING THE MASKS OR WAS THAT
BECAUSE THE DEBATE COMMISSION
MADE THAT A RULE?
>> WELL, THAT IS BECAUSE THEY
ASKED US TO WEAR THE MASKS THE
WHOLE TIME.
AGAIN I CONTINUE TO REITERATE
THE FIRST TIME AROUND WAS NOT
MADE PERFECTLY CLEAR US TO.
WE WALKED IN WITH THEM AND
THOUGHT WE WERE OKAY TO TAKE
THEM OFF WHEN WE SAT DOWN.
HAPPY TO KEEP THEM ON IF THAT
WAS THE RULE AND THAT’S WHAT WE
DID.
>> Sandra: FINAL QUESTION ON
WOMEN VOTERS.
WE CAN PUT UP ON THE SCREEN THE
NEW FOX NEWS STATE POLLING ON
JOE BIDEN HOW HE IS POLLING
VERSUS THE PRESIDENT WITH
SUBURBAN WOMEN.
YOU CAN CLEARLY SEE THAT JOE
BIDEN IS RUNNING UP THE SCORE
AMONG SUBURBAN WOMEN.
THIS CONCERN THE CAMPAIGN AND
WHAT ARE YOU DOING TO TRY TO
CHANGE SOME OF THOSE MINDS?
>> WE CONTINUE TO REACH OUT TO
ALL AMERICANS INCLUDING WOMEN.
I’M BE ON THE WOMEN FOR TRUMP
BUS THIS WEEK IN MY HOME STATE
OF NORTH CAROLINA ALONG WITH
GREAT FEMALE SURROGATES FROM
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN GOING TO
TALK ABOUT THE PRESIDENT’S
TRACK RECORD.
WHAT HE HAS DONE FOR WOMEN
ACROSS AMERICA IN THE PAST FOUR
YEARS.
WHAT HE PLANS TO DO NOT ONLY TO
GET THE ECONOMY BACK BUT TO
KEEP EVERYBODY SAFE IN AMERICA.
GET SCHOOLS BACK OPEN.
THOSE ARE IMPORTANT ISSUES TO
WOMEN ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
>> Sandra: A COUPLE SECONDS
LEFT.
IF WE CAN PUT UP THE SCREEN THE
EARLY VOTE COUNT TOTAL.
EVERYBODY IS TALKING ABOUT THIS.
THE HUGE NUMBER SO FAR OF OVER
47 MILLION HAVE CAST THEIR
BALLOTS EARLY VERSUS THIS POINT
IN 2016.
IT’S ABOUT 10 MILLION MORE.
IS THIS SOMETHING THAT THE
CAMPAIGN IS CONCERNED ABOUT?
IS THIS A GOOD SIGN FOR JOE
BIDEN AND HOW DO YOU ANALYZE
THAT?
>> WE’VE BEEN ENCOURAGING OUR
VOTERS TO GET OUT AND VOTE
EARLY.
IF YOUR STATE OFFERS EARLY
VOTING VOTE NOW, GET YOUR VOTE
LOCKED IN.
FOR THE PRESIDENT YOU LOOK AT
STATES LIKE MICHIGAN.
WE’RE FAR AHEAD WITH EARLY VOTE
AND MAIL-IN VOTING TOTALS.
WAY AHEAD OF WHERE A REPUBLICAN
HAS BEEN BEFORE.
THESE ARE LOOKING RATHER
POSITIVE FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
A SIGN THAT HOPEFULLY PEOPLE
ARE LISTENING TO US AND GETTING
OUT AND VOTING EARLY.
I HOPE WE SEE THOSE RESULTS IN
A BIG WAY FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP